hey it's Justine and today we are
checking out Final Cut Pro for the iPad
now I've been using this for about a
week and I really like it but here's the
thing that I'm going to tell you if you
are a traditional editor coming from
Final Cut on desktop or even Premiere
and you've never really used any type of
touch based editing I would suggest for
getting everything that you know and
come into this with like a completely
new mind because I jumped into this
thinking I was going to be editing like
I do on the desktop and I got a little
frustrated because a lot of the things
that I would do on my desktop you do
them a little bit differently here which
is way more efficient for touch and
sometimes it can actually be faster so
once I kind of got over that hurdle and
just forgot everything that I knew and
came into this like I've never edited
before I really really started loving it
a few things that I would like that this
would do is have external drive support
you can plug in a drive and save all of
those files into your library but you
can't edit directly off of an external
drive I also wish you could send it to
your Mac and then send that Library back
but once you send it to the Mac you
can't bring Library back and continue to
edit I do hope in a next version or in
an update that those are some things
that they will allow but for now here it
is okay so I'm going to start a new
project you can make your project name
so I'm going to say
scuba just that's me this automatically
has it set at 59.94 frames we're gonna
do 24 frames per second and when we hit
next this is where you decide where you
import your footage from you can import
from photos files you can start
completely blank or you can even record
with the iPad camera which is pretty
cool and to import them you basically
just drag
and then you click add and this will
automatically create your project and
it'll download all of that media from
the cloud and as you can see all of my
stuff is here and ready to edit now we
have a couple of options over here we
have this insert so you can overwrite it
playhead insert it playhead connect it
playhead or append to storyline so I'm
going to put this entire clip into here
because this is kind of a little story
that I'm telling and I'm going to add
some b-roll and stuff over top of it
I just finished my first part of getting
scuba certified here all of the clips
are super easy to adjust you can just
drag and it'll automatically clip it
right there so I'm going to do the same
at the end here dragging this all the
way across here can get a little tiring
so they have this thing called the jog
wheel which you can access right up here
and this brings up a little wheel and
this allows you to scrub through the
timeline really really fast and this is
what really kind of flipped the switch
for me of like oh I get it everything is
kind of made to be sort of edited like
this if that makes sense like you kind
of have access and the reachability is
all in here so you have your inspect
volume animate multi-cam and you have
all of your buttons down here to be able
to trim delete select and everything is
just within like your thumb's reach that
for me was kind of like when my mind
switched into like oh everything that I
knew before I'm gonna forget and
completely relearn it okay so right here
there's kind of a space so I'm gonna hit
this little select button down here and
then I can zoom in to see okay I don't
want that anymore delete
play
one of the most difficult Parts was
having to take off my mask while I'm
under the water and then so now I'm just
going to delete this rest of this clip
and it makes it so easy because you can
just hit this little button right here
that gets rid of everything to the right
hand side of it and it'll just keep that
clip now I do like having the keyboard
for things like hitting up and it'll
take you to the beginning of Clips
hitting down I also love just being able
to hit spacebars this is my first so
nice so those types of things I've still
been using the keyboard for you don't
have to but it is just it's just easy
because the keyboard's there most of the
shortcut keys have transferred over from
Final Cut so if you are familiar with
those a lot of them will work here as
well okay this video is great we love it
it's vertical grates that's a mistake so
we're gonna put one of these backgrounds
I'm gonna add in this one and then we're
just going to drag it to the end love to
see it so now I'm going to add a title
there's a bunch of custom titles in here
that they already have pre-made since
I'm just lazy we're gonna just drag this
one right here and I'm going to change
that to say
diving in the Maldives inside of the
inspector this gives you a lot of
different options like you can change
the font the size color I'm fine with
this
I just finished my first we've also got
effects so when you scroll through here
we've got a bunch of different effects
there's hard lights and I think that's a
little too harsh so I'm actually going
to add it to 0.51 that looks great I'm
gonna go in here to the volume and this
inspector tab we're gonna go back in
here and go to the audio this lets you
turn the volume up you also have voice
isolation so I'm going to turn that to
about 25 I'm gonna add some loudness
let's see what that sounds like I just
finished my first part of getting scuba
certified here in the mall okay now
let's start adding in some clips over
top of this so something that I
originally was going to be doing in
Catalina so I'm talking about getting
certified so I'm going to scroll up here
and these are our in and out points now
the thing you can also do is you can hit
these little arrows to get your in and
out or because I love shortcut keys you
can I for o and then this is where we're
going to want to change this up here so
we're going to want to do connected
playhead because that's going to allow
it to go over top of this footage now
again because I'm a keyboard freak I
would usually hit q but because we're in
our touch base environment we'll just
hit connect I'm gonna start that here
and then we're going to turn that volume
down because we don't want that volume
we want me talking so something that I
originally was going to be doing in
Catalina with my sister but I figure
this place is so beautiful and it's one
of the best places you can add a picture
here connect
we'll head start so the one thing I will
note is if you do forget if you're in
the volume and you're trying to edit
these clips click out of that and
that'll let you get back to your Clips
so let's make this a little bit shorter
love it I think I might want to put
another clip over top of here connect
volume down
sport person I'm not like the strongest
of swimmers but like I clearly trim the
end let's add a transition here
let's do a zoom and pan
can drag it right to our clip
I clearly can actually swim which I
didn't even know that I could do you can
also drag this up if you want to see
more of your timeline and I'm going to
be adding some more things in here so
I'm going to go into my options and
appearance and I'm going to adjust this
clip height a little bit so I can get
more real estate here this is so lovely
but let's add some music because it's a
little boring I need some tunes now
these soundtracks they're built into
final cut these are Dynamic so when you
choose a song watch this magic so you
can see this thing is so long so I'm
gonna go to about right here and we are
going to trim off the rest of it and did
you see that did you see that it
automatically adjusted so when I drag it
the end adjusts
oh my God it's perfect it's beautiful
it's beautiful I freaking love
we also got some objects here let's add
a little thumbs up
like the strongest this one you can move
them all around it's so intuitive love
it
let's go back and add another little
clip here maybe like a little turtle oh
he's so cool we're gonna add that right
here volume down
I never know that I could do
um
live type here we go
now you see the live drawing shows up
right here
so I had to go through oh there it is
I want this to be a little slower so I'm
going to adjust this so that this ends
about right here so we go into our
inspector and you can edit that right
here with your draw time
so I want it to be about right
here I do
um so I had to go through all sorts of
things today it's pretty slow right but
that's the vibe that I was going for so
let's film a quick little video here
since I'm back from diving I want to let
everyone know I survived and I got
certified they have some new added tools
here so you can adjust the exposure so
let's
we're going to adjust it to about oh my
gosh wow this is really close to my face
okay and then
we're gonna do the color temperature
actually that looks
that looks pretty good to me and then
we're gonna hit record hi so I am back
from diving I had so much fun and I
actually got scuba certified for my open
water diving and it was the most fun
ever here's a picture of me and my
instruction
I messed up so hold on here's a picture
of me and my instructor Morgan she was
so incredible and so patient and I had
the best time can't wait to go back to
the Maldives okay we did that hit done
and that will pop up in our library so
let's change this here let's append a
story so that'll automatically add it
right where we left off so bye
so I talked about I had so much fun
diving where did I mess up okay so I'll
just hit this here and then I hit the
Little Slice button
and then slice again
delete that
here's a picture of me and my instructor
Morgan she was let's find our picture of
me and Morgan there's a photo
and there's a photo okay there we go
there's our photo I'll actually make
this a little bit bigger and I'm gonna
move myself over here's the picture me
and
my instructor Morgan she was so
incredible and so patient and I've had
the best time can't wait to go back to
the Maldives and there's our video
you can do some color correction here we
can change our exposure I'm actually
gonna
click this so I can see
my color a little bit better I'm going
to add a little saturation turn the
black points up a little change the tint
just a tad make it a little bit warmer
and there we go you can turn this on and
off by clicking disable so you can see
the color on off on
off
we'll keep it on so I like to be a
little more particular with my audio so
I'm going to go in here into the volume
and I'm going to actually add my own
keyframe this is the keyframe button
right here
so I'm going to hit that and then I'm
going to go over here make another one
so over here we have to use our little
jog wheel and this will let you turn the
volume up and down
so I had to go through all sorts of
things today and then I want the audio
to go back down like about here just
like that so that's some of the basics
of Final Cut here for iPad something
else that I love I'm going to start a
whole new project here just to show you
the multi-cam feature so I'm going to
click down here for new MultiCam we're
going to select our clips
unboxing we're gonna synchronize using
audio there we have it our multi-cam is
right here I freaking love multicam it's
one of my favorite Final Cut features so
you're basically going to be edit by
touch so you can just choose which angle
you want oh look at this I'm coming in
now as I drop the package I'm gonna cut
to two
so I come in
here's the package looks great cut back
to me and then I talk too much so let's
just cut to where I start actually
unboxing so I start unboxing right about
here so I'm going to delete everything
before it I'm going to use the jog wheel
to cut to about right here and then
where do I actually do anything else I
start taking it out right about here so
I'm going to delete everything before
that let's see if this works copy
okay we're gonna paste it we're gonna
put that on top so I'm able to nudge
this to line it directly up with the
bottom so we're going to move this over
I'm actually going to crop it here we go
remove that right there
and then that should give us a nice
two shot and then it cuts back to the
bag now another new feature that they
have on here is background removal so
here's me talking let's go into
our effects scroll down to the scene
removal mask and there we go it did a
pretty decent job so I could actually
improve this a little bit I can cut out
the bottom I'm gonna add a new
background this paper I'll drag this
under there
oh yeah that's some text
I'm gonna use that jog wheel nudge that
over
and there we have it
not bad at all so that my friends is
Final Cut Pro for the iPad I am so
excited for the future of touch-based
editing I feel like it really is the
next Generation way of editing I edit so
much on my phone but to be able to have
a bigger device something that is purely
dedicated to the Final Cut ecosystem I'm
so excited about it I have started a
little notepad of a wish list of things
that I want and some questions that I
have so if you guys have any questions
or wish list of things that you would
like to see included in the new Final
Cut for ipad please leave me some
comments below